can you watch a football game with
friends like just sit there and just
watch as a fan or they always you get
peppered with questions no not too much
a little bit but yes I do as a matter of
fact most Monday nights I have a couple
buddies who come over and and and we
watch the games and and then with the
Thursday night gig I've had an
opportunity to watch some Sunday games
when we've been off a couple of times
and yeah so I'm a fan like everyone else
when I get a chance to be alright but
then do you have the guy the buddy who
thinks he knows as much as you know oh
of course
yeah absolutely you know you wonder
sometimes if they realize you know I
don't know if they know who they're
sitting next to but you know it's it's
interesting a lot of a lot of guys who
seem to have all the answers and I you
know what you find that though Dan when
you just go to a high school football
game just sit with the parents there's
some of the best coaches in the world
Fitness fans watching these high school
you should keep a Super Bowl ring in
your pocket just in case if you need to
slip it alright a couple things here
what's missing in Pittsburgh aside from
the obvious with Le'Veon Bell what is
missing with this team uh you know it's
an interesting dynamic there in
Pittsburgh you know I thought for
instance I thought Todd Haley was a good
offensive coordinator I thought he'd
done a nice job overall for the time
that he was there and and for whatever
reason that didn't work out it seemed
like it was more of a personality issue
than than anything else and and then
we've seen obviously a lot of grumblings
here in the the the last few weeks and I
think teams go through that at times
teams that have been together players
coaches whatever it might be but there's
no doubt that that that takes away from
what's happening on the field you know
who knows maybe they maybe they've they
can pull it together I happen to think
that they can with the players that they
have but when you don't have someone as
talented his lady on bail and as much as
he's meant to that team you know that's
uh not that that's all of it like you
said but that's a big part of it as well
what you make of the Cowboys Seahawks
game it looking at the Cowboys offense
now I know that Jerry Jones allude
- hey we're sort of similar to the LA
Rams yes you solve the Rams on Thursday
night yeah I don't think anybody's
similar to the Rams you know I think
that the players they have one or
terrific of Brandon cooks I've been a
huge fan here since he came into the
league a few years back and then McBay
but I the the Cowboys they're still
they've gotten Ezekiel Elliott gone they
did against Seattle they did yesterday
again with Detroit as you would expect
but they still are not just pulling it
all together within the passing game and
I and and although better and they were
able to get some big plays that's what's
been lacking I still think that that
part of their offense has to be better
if they're ultimately going to achieve
what they hope to have you ever seen a
situation with Earl Thomas what you saw
yesterday where he flips off his own
sidelines not quite like that
I witnessed quite a bit in Dallas over
the years when I was playing but you
know obviously just a lot of frustration
on his part I thought it was interesting
when we had the the Seahawks as you as
you mentioned with the Cowboys how into
the game he was and he had not from what
I was told when we were there at their
facility he had not really talked to
anybody in the building outside of just
teammates and and yet on that Sunday and
and maybe it was because he thought it
might be the last game that he played
for Seattle and that ultimately that's
this past week he was going to be
playing for the Cowboys I'm not sure but
he was certainly into the game showing a
lot of enthusiasm excitement throughout
that game and then have happened what
happened yesterday is obviously a real
letdown and that's why these players
want these big contracts but I think you
know Earl's a he's an intense guy and
and just a lot of frustration came out
in that moment no doubt it's not gonna
Troy Aikman joining a Stan Patrick's
show I'm gonna run down some numbers
here and you tell me where we're headed
with this back in 2014
eleven 400-yard passing performances
that's the entire season 2015 10 2016 12
2017
eight such games so far through 62 games
we've had 12 400 yard passing games
where we are enjoy well wherever we're
headed I think it's where the league
wanted because of the rules that they
put our not so much the rules but the
emphasis this year on illegal contact
defensive holding they wanted to see
scoring up it was down from last season
and it's worked you know so we're seeing
a lot of yards as you as you said and a
lot of offense and and that's what
that's what fans want III think it's I
think it's great it's more fun for me to
call games when there's a lot of scoring
we saw that with the Vikings and and
Rams last Thursday night
but yeah it's a different game clearly
and that's what that's why I say that
this this you know we go when we talked
to coaches every week obviously and and
yeah we we still have coaches who say
well we got to run the ball got stop the
run 1970 I mean that games been changed
a long time ago and and you better stop
the past you know I understand yeah we
want to stop the run but if you can't
play past the defense and you can't
throw the ball on this league you're
just simply not going to win which
segues into tonight with Patrick mahomes
you know we keep waiting for he comes
back down to earth does he come back
down to earth tonight against Denver
Troy oh you know I
you'd like to think or you know the the
law of averages would say that this pace
can't continue but what an impressive
young guy he is and and I'm looking
forward to watching him play tonight I
haven't had a chance to really sit and
watch him we'll have Kansas City at some
point on the only Thursday night to
where I'll really be able to study him
but yeah I've heard nothing but
wonderful things about him as as a
person and then of course the way that
he's come out and played and it's pretty
remarkable and you know Alex Smith had
had a great year last year yeah and and
yet they were ready to to give this
young guy a chance and see what he could
do and he's taking advantage of it and
it'll be fun I'm interested in watching
him not as well but I do think he's
going to continue to have a great
career but I think with Andy Reid and I
give the Chiefs credit because Alex
Smith would have been the safe
quarterback to keep and use the draft
pick or draft picks on something else
that could help this team they needed to
stretch the field because they weren't
scaring anybody 20 yards downfield
and if I got Kelsey and I got Hill I I
got a chance that you know Sammy Watkins
I got a chance to hurt you and then you
have to at least acknowledge the play
fake there so Kansas City went all-in
with Alex Smith being a very good
quarterback well that's right and and as
we know when you take a quarterback in
the first round I mean it's it's it's
not a foregone conclusion that the guy
is going to be a success it's it's about
a 50-50 chance and so there was a lot of
risk a lot of belief in him I went back
and studied in this offseason and
studied a number of these quarterbacks
that I hadn't gotten a chance to really
see there wasn't much tape to watch on
mahomes he played you know in the season
finale you played in the preseason and
and although I thought he did some good
things in week 17 last year there were
also some moments where you say yeah you
know he's a young player who just simply
hasn't played but but yet there was
excitement in Kansas City about his
future and and so people were right on
him at least to this point and it you
know I mean I I think obviously as I
said he's going to continue to play
really well he's gonna have a great
career in Kansas City and seems to have
the makeup that you want from that
position but it was not without risk to
make the move and yet it has paid off
and and and that team has a lot of
talent around him and they're utilizing
that so Andy's done an amazing job he
has shown that ability everywhere he's
been in an ability to to to play within
the the strengths of a quarterback and
and and be creative offensively and
that's been an exciting group to see we
don't see Kansas City like I said doing
the NFC package with Fox but I will this
year now with Thursday nights and I've
got to believe that they're right up
there with the Rams as far as offensive
firepower how much heat does Frank Reich
deserve with his play calling they're
not going for the time that was a that
was a little bit of a head-scratcher
I I think primarily because they if you
don't make it there you know unlike
Rabil if you don't make it there then
just one pass and all of a sudden you're
losing the game you know whereas with
Mike Vrabel going for it they weren't
close to giving up a field goal if you
know and all that so
MoDOT that the success of the Eagles
last year going forward on fourth down
and Frank Reich being a part of that
team has has changed I think the
approach with a number of coaches and I
think that played into it yesterday and
I heard what everyone said after the
game and I'd have to you know you don't
want to tie but you'd rather die than
lose so that's probably one he'd like
that back but you know when the results
are when you have the hind side of the
results then then it's easy to say that
but at the time I thought that it was a
pretty risky call and it ended up
backfiring on but if you're the
quarterback don't you love that or your
your team like you I know we look at the
results but but if in the moment you're
like hell yeah like if you're Andrew
Luck aren't you saying that where are
you thinking yeah I believe so I was in
95 I was with the Cowboys when Barry
Switzer went for it twice on 4th and 1
and and we didn't make it and I had a
penalty the first time we went for it
again and and we were backed up we ended
up losing the game and I was all for
that decision because I felt that with
the conditions in the game that if we
didn't pick up the first down there we
were gonna lose anyway and we saw Bill
Belichick go for it against Peyton when
he was with the Colts backed up and and
he felt that if they didn't make the
first down there on fourth down they
were going to lose the game anyway and
so III think there's something to be
said for that
I didn't disagree with Bello checks call
at the time I didn't disagree with with
Switzer's call at the time the
circumstances I think were a little bit
different but I think in the long run if
you if you play aggressively III do like
that I think there's a tendency for
coaches to play a little bit too close
to the vest I think for the most
our coaches make decisions because it's
it's what's going to draw the least
amount of scrutiny after the fact so on
the one hand you'd say yeah I mean good
for Frank you know believing in his team
and and trying to pull out a win it just
didn't work you know and whether or not
he makes that same decision in the
future we'll find out but yeah it's just
disappointing then that you have a tie
and you ultimately end up losing the
game
Troy good to visit with you again tell
Joe we said hello and hopefully we'll
talk to you soon sure well thank you but
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]